Speaker 1: All right, I was not
initially going to do this story,
so many of you wrote to me about it that I'm
going to do it, but I want to again mention
that there's a lot going on right now with Ron
DeSantis. His wife is is in cancer treatment. And
I just want to be careful with with this story.
The backstory on this is that Ron DeSantis, the
Republican Florida governor who maybe mismanaged
COVID more than any other governor in the country,
at least up there in the top five, basically went
missing publicly for two weeks. On December 17th,
a bagel place in Ocala, Florida, posted
a picture of DeSantis being there.
DeSantis was then missing from the public for
13 days on December 30th, posted a picture
from that same bagel place the same picture,
saying Go get bagels. But at that point,
we knew that picture was almost two weeks old, so
it didn't really allay concerns about where is he
and the speculation was. Did he have COVID? And he
had to go out of the public eye for some period of
time because he didn't want to publicly admit that
he had COVID? It was speculative, without a doubt.
Then it was stated No, no, no, no, no.
Ron DeSantis was busy going to his wife's
cancer treatment completely legitimate, except the
statement was that that was only on December 29th.
It doesn't really explain his 12 days of absence
dating back to December 17th. On New Year's Eve,
DeSantis surfaced at a big concert with his wife,
who again is immunocompromised. She's undergoing
cancer treatment. No masks. Very, very dangerous
thing to do. And the speculation continued to be
was the sand is hiding COVID for that period of
time. A video has now been released from yesterday
in which Ron DeSantis something is very wrong
with Ron DeSantis. His voice is quivering. He's
out of breath. He's struggling to breathe. Kind
of like Trump when Trump. Remember when Trump
left the hospital with COVID and he defiantly
took off his mask? And then you could see
Trump really, really struggling to breathe? It's a
similar thing with DeSantis, but at the same time,
he kind of seems almost in tears, and maybe
there was a setback with his wife's treatment. So
let's take a look at it. And we I don't
know what's going on. This could be
the additional evidence that he's been
hiding. COVID could be that his wife had a bad
treatment day or a setback. I don't know, but
let's take a look and let's take a listen.
Speaker 4: By Dane Eagle, who's our Florida CEO
secretary. We also have Chancellor Henry Mack
from the Florida Department of Education.
Speaker 1: So this part is more COVID like,
which is when you speak speaking is
more effort than people might realize.
And a lot of times with COVID, it's this having
to really labor each breath to keep speaking. So
far later, it seems more like he's almost crying.
Speaker 4: Brad Ferguson, senior VP and general
manager, Sky Water Florida, and Gail
Miller, Site Director, Sky Water Florida,
as well as Representative Fred Hawkins.
Manufacturing is something that we need.
Speaker 1: And you can hear that breath is,
you know, you did the the multiple short breaths
to try to keep up with the oxygen in needs
Speaker 4: better job of. And
we've worked really hard in Florida
to have more opportunities with vocational
education. We have expanded our manufacturing
footprint in the state of Florida and we want to
continue to be able to do that as we go forward.
Speaker 1: So now is where it starts shifting
into. It's not just the trouble breathing.
He starts to sound on the verge of tears.
Speaker 4: Semiconductors are a huge issue.
If you look at how the supply chain works,
we are overly dependent on foreign nations,
including Taiwan, which is a good ally
of ours, but which is one that excuse me,
which is one that is under really serious
pressure from the Communist Party of China.
And so we have an opportunity to do more here in
the United States. And I think the more we can do
manufacturing of semiconductors here, the better
off will be. So today I'm proud to be awarding $6
million to build infrastructure that will connect
southern Osceola County to the emerging Neo City
Technology District. This district is already home
to six companies, including Sky Water Technology,
a U.S. owned and operated semiconductor foundry.
Well, this award will support nearly 50 400 jobs.
Osceola County officials estimate that this could
lead to tens of thousands of jobs once it's fully
developed as Osceola County continues to grow. I'm
also awarding Valencia College with $3.7 million
to create new programs that focus on workforce
training for chip and semiconductor industries.
Through this program, students will be able to see
certified and operating, repairing and designing
the robots that are used to create semiconductors
in just 14 weeks. Valencia estimates that in the
first two years, one hundred and twenty people
will be able to graduate and immediately find
work at the Neo City Technology District.
Speaker 1: All right, so listen, I mean, I
want to be careful with this. His wife has cancer.
It would be logical to be crying if her treatment
weren't going well. But we don't know what this
is. Certainly, you know, the back story he's
missing two weeks posts a picture that's two weeks
old to show that he's actually out there, says
he was accompanying his wife to cancer treatment,
but that apparently was only on one day 12 days in
and then reappears using accessory muscles to
breathe and taking these short gasping breaths and
just having a it's it's all weird. It's all
really weird. And it reminds me of Trump on the
White House balcony after taking off the mask and
breathing like that. And we know why we know you
know what the reason was for Trump doing that. So
are we ever going to get the truth? I don't know.
Is it reasonable to think that DeSantis would
hide COVID if that's what he had? Yes, absolutely.
I mean, there's no doubt in my mind and this was
there was the idea of hiding Trump's COVID as
well. It became impossible. It was just it's
not going to be possible once the facts became
known of how serious it was once the reality sort
of set in. But absolutely, DeSantis would hide
COVID. Is that what this is? I don't really know.